what is the probability that Russia
attacks Ukraine with a tactical nuclear
weapon
well Putin Stephanie
be right I mean he's the kind of person
if he's got an instrument he wants to
figure out how to use it you know we
look at polonium we look at novichok you
know we look at all kinds of things you
know that he's also presided over in
Syria he has you know put in charge of
the war in Ukraine now uh General
civilikin is known as general Armageddon
you know the kind of person who you know
pretty much facilitated the use of
chemical weapons in Syria you know for
example so you know don't think that
Putin you know hasn't thought about how
ruthless he can possibly be the question
is really the calculation it says his
estimation of the probability that we'll
get the desired effect
we keep talking about this idea of
escalate de-escalate that's not what the
Russians you know how they call it but
it's the whole idea that you do
something really outrageous to get
everybody else to back off yeah now when
you talked about the precedent that the
United States set of detonating uh the
nuclear weapons in Hiroshima Nagasaki
what you know he obviously meant the
president of using nuclear weapons of
course which of course we would then say
well we should then how the Imp
permissibility of ever doing that again
but what he's talking about is the
precedent of escalating to such an
extent that you stopped the war because
he reads that saying well you know the
US dropped the bombs on Hiroshima
Nagasaki the war was brought to a quick
conclusion and of course there's a huge
debate in America about whether it was
necessary to do that whether the war was
ending anywhere did that really you know
kind of uh change the minds of the
Japanese High command I mean there's all
kind of books and being written about
that
and of course you know the revulsion
that people felt um in the wake of that
was just you know just the shock of of
what actually happened and we've spent
you know 70 years you know basically
Coming to Terms of the fact that we did
something like that you know the fire
bombing you know we've also looked at
all the bombing you know in Vietnam and
everywhere and you know the the all
these massive bombing campaigns are
realizing they actually often had the
opposite effect Hiroshima Nagasaki might
have uh contributed and there's a lot of
you know scholarship suggesting it did
to the end of the war but all of the big
bombing campaigns the destruction
actually prolonged was because they made
people fight back as we're kind of
seeing in the case of Ukraine so Putin
has to calculate the probability that if
he uses some tactical nuclear weapon
that it'll get the desired effect which
is get us to capitulate and Ukraine to
capitulate it us to capitulate meaning
the United States and the Europeans not
supporting Ukraine anymore pushing
towards the negotiating table
negotiating Ukraine away and Ukraine is
saying okay we give up like um happened
in Hiroshima and Nagasaki or in Japan
ton so it's it's his calculation you
know as much as anything else which is
really important he said we have to show
him that he won't get that out of it
it's kind of less our probability and
you know kind of the odds of it it's
just how he calculates that probability
what he wants I mean I guess that's how
the game of poker works it's your your
probability and your estimate of their
probability and your estimate of their
estimate of your probability and yeah so
it goes on yeah exactly uh I think he
has two tools right so one is actually
the actual use of nuclear weapons and
then the threat of these oh this is very
effective and the more real you make the
threat that's right so if they get uh
the more you approach the actual use I
get very close to you it's already using
Chernobyl
and then usual cranes the other nuclear
reactors so he's using civilian nuclear
actors as a dirty bomb so you know it's
ironic that he has Sega shagu his
defense minister calling people
obviously the ukraines are going to use
a dirty bomb they're already doing it I
mean what what what is um you know kind
of more destructive and stirring up all
the radioactive dust and chernobylas you
send your troops through you know for
example or shelling you know the the
Chernobyl plants and the sarcophagus and
putting it at risk and zap Parisian
you've got the international atomic
energy agency running out there in a
panic and you know kind of also trying
to intervene in the conflict so you're
putting you know civilian nuclear uh
reactors at risk I mean that also has a
great added effect of cutting off
Ukraine's power supply because
zapparesia in particular was the
opposite a third of them Ukraine's power
generation or some you know really high
percentage job but I'd have to go back
and you know take a look at that but
that's the two for you know it's a kind
of a double effect there of undermining
uh Power Generation also frightening
Germans and others who've already been
very worried about nuclear power and you
know increasing your leverage on that
energy front but also scaring people uh
from the perspective of uh the use of
nuclear weapon those reactors also
become a nuclear weapon tactically
deployed and as you said that the
discussion of using a nuclear weapon and
engendering all those fears and he's
already got an effect everyone's running
around talking about the Cuban Missile
Crisis and secret diplomacy and how we
negotiate away Ukraine in return for not
blowing up a nuclear weapon so he's got
a lot of people obviously talking about
that so sorry for the difficult and uh
direct question it could be for you
directly or more like uh do you think we
have a plan for this what happens if he
does
drop a nuclear
weapon do you have a sense that the
United States
has a good plan
I know we're talking about it I think we
probably have several plans because it
depends on what where when how
but that don't and also don't these
things happen very quickly
well there's also signaling and sign and
signs of um of movement there I mean I
want to be very you know kind of careful
about this but and the thing is it's
also very important that we do this with
other nuclear Powers so the other thing
that's different
from how it might have been in the past
and particularly different from the
Cuban Missile Crisis near a missile
crisis we're not the only nuclear
players
China I mean has emerging nuclear
Arsenal now
um Less on the Strategic side but
building it up uh but very much on the
intermediate uh range and Tactical
Kim Jong-un is firing off weapons left
right and Center at the moment in North
Korea we've got other Rogue States
Putin's behaving like a rogue State just
to be very clear and this is what we've
got with Kim Jong-un in North Korea
we've also got India and Pakistan and
we've got other states that we're not
supposed to talk about that we know have
nuclear capacities and others that would
like to have nuclear capacity and the
whole questioner here is about ulcer
proliferation getting back to that time
when Ukraine had nuclear weapons at
least there on its terrorism so the
Belarus and Kazakhstan you've got to
wonder was it wise for them to give it
up we were worried about you know kind
of loose nukes nuclear weapons you know
kind of uh getting out of hand
proliferation at the time we wanted
fewer nuclear Powers Russia wanted that
too now we're going to have more we've
got more and what Putin is saying is
well that was stupid of Ukraine to give
up the nuclear weapons in fact my
colleagues and I back in our report Back
in the USSR kind of suggest they
shouldn't give them up
and that's why we had the um Budapest
memorandum that's why the United States
the United Kingdom in particular
have you know basically some
responsibility and obligation going back
to 1994 when they promised you Crane
That gave up the nuclear weapons their
territorial integrity and sovereignty
would remain intact some obligation to
actually do something to step up if we
step back from that this is the thing
that people are not talking about
you know what about nuclear
proliferation if you're South Korea
Japan you know you're any other country
that's kind of worrying about your
neighbors
um and you know what might happen to you
I mean just like India and Pakistan are
both like well you know we've got to
kind of keep our strategic nuclear
balance here everything is up for
questions Saudis will want a nuclear
weapon the Turks already want one
they've talked about one for years you
know why should the Iranians be the only
one with an Islamic nuclear weapon you
know and if if we know that you know
Iran has
break up capacity now the Saudis and all
the other you know states that are in
opposition to Iran well I also want to
have some nuclear capacity in the United
States before wanted to maintain
everything under the nuclear umbrella no
one of the reasons why Sweden and
Finland are joining NATO is because of
suddenly all of these nuclear threats
Sweden was actually the Lost country on
the planet to want to have nuclear
weapons they were actually pushing for a
ban on nuclear weapons in the United
Nations now that Putin's doing the
nuclear cyber rattling
you know they're talking about joining
and on the verge of joining a nuclear
Alliance you know see what what's
happening here so we have to make it
more and more difficult for Putin to
even contemplate that that's why people
are saying this is reckless this is
irresponsible Putin is actually making
the world less safe for himself down the
line either but he's thinking short term
here he's thinking what can I do what do
I actually have you can also destroy
lots of infrastructure as he's doing
you can use subversion you know we're
worried about all of the undersea cables
all these weird things happening you
know off orkney or in the Mediterranean
or you know all these other things that
are happening not stream to pipelines
other infrastructure there's all kinds
of other things that he can do as well
here it's not just you know again
there's a civilian nuclear threat
of blowing up you know one of the
reactors
now it's got to be sure about where the
wind turns and the wind blows
and there's all kinds of things to you
know factor in here but Putin is
definitely sitting around
calculating with other people what can I
do to turn this around I mean he still
thinks that he can win this
or in other words he can oh he can end
it in on his terms Crimea done yet
and you know capitulation all recognized
as being part of Russia
oh he can freeze it and then you know
kind of figure about where it goes from
there what other pressure he can put on
I mean I'm sure he's confident he can
get rid of zelenski and and he can
Prevail over us I mean look I mean the
UK is going through Prime Ministers you
know faster than I'm changing my socks
you know so it's like uh you know he can
you know Prevail on the um you know
basically he can
it can have an impact on the political
scene in Europe and elsewhere I mean
again everyone's talking about winter
coming and I know Putin's thinking yeah
great I've you know destroyed the
infrastructure of
you're worried about the winter
well yeah but I mean look the other
thing is that is that we should start
preparing I mean
I mean to start thinking about this
we've got
I'm economy situation
where we are we've got the home front to
think about as well Putin has declared
war on us we did that on September 30th
and so he's done it at other points as
well we've just not paid attention but
he pretty was pretty explicit in
September 30th let me go back and watch
that speech
and you know he
is gambling that you know people will go
back you know to basically taking
Russian gas and oil but it's not going
to be that simple as well and do people
and then you know the question has to be
do we really kind of think he's going to
play a fair after that well he's kind of
also shown that he can leverage that
it's such a complicated world it is
complicated it's very complex it's never
I mean this it feels like things are
heating up
like
and China
is very quiet right now because they're
watching what happens I mean for
president she
you know is trying to consolidate his
power even further after the party
Congress but he doesn't want to look
like he made a mistake by bucking Putin
I mean he thought Putin was also going
to be you know
Ukraine would probably be open for
massive Chinese investment China was the
largest investor in Ukraine
before the ball
largest single investor I mean the EU is
bigger of course